welcome to this joint overview and
scrutiny committee meeting
i'm councillor keith welland and i will
be chairing the meeting today
may i first remind you of some domestic
arrangements
please ensure that you maintain social
distancing from all other persons whilst
in the chamber and in the communal areas
please ensure that you are wearing a
face covering at all times unless you
are sitting down or if you are exempt
from doing so
and please use the sand the hand
sanitizer and wipes provided
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations whilst
others are speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure that your mobile phones
are unsilent or switched off
we will be using e-voting for this
meeting on the modern.gov app so please
could members make sure they are logged
in those who can and are ready to use
the app
i'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to be recorded
by the council and to the possible use
for those sound recordings for
webcasting
and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
if you hear the alarm please leave the
building immediately via a fire exit and
then make your way to the assembly point
which is the ipswich town football
ground
follow the signs directing you to the
fire exits at each end of the floor
do not enter the atrium
the ground floor area and walkways if
you are in the atrium at the time of the
alarm follow the signs to the nearest
fire exit
use the stairs not the lifts
do not re-enter the building until told
it is safe to do so
so
can we have a
reader of the
people who are attending we've got we've
obviously got members of the committee
and we have various offices who are
either here or will be appearing
thank you chair so this morning we have
the offices of samantha lake who is the
corporate manager for customer
operations vicki mosley corporate
manager for communities peter watson
community safety project manager ian
rafferty community safety officer justin
king
housing needs standards manager
um and we have cabinet members here this
morning with councillor susie morley
councillor jan osborne and council
alastair mccraw thank you
thank you
so can i move to the agenda please
we have some apologies for absence
and under substitution i believe
thank you chair
this morning we have apologies from
councillor mary mclaren with councillor
suez subbing
and
apologies from councillor catherine
brandon and apologies from councillor
jane gould
and also councillor carson as well yes
james caston's had to leave thank you
are there any declarations of pecuniary
and non-pecuniary interest by members
councillor mayberry
no you can't press the button
nothing happens um yes uh there is a
comment further into the papers this
morning which mentions citizens advice i
declare that i am a director of
submarine district citizens advice thank
you
councillor muller um yes thank you chair
i should declare that i'm a trustee of
the mid-suffolk sydney's advice thank
you thank you very much
can we now confirm the minutes of the
meeting of the joint overview and
scrutiny committee held on the 19th of
july 2021
are there any points recording the
accuracy of the minutes please
council barrett
um
although it wasn't there reading it it
doesn't make sense um
this on point 88 1
it's it says the chair referred to the
question that had been received by
thomas morelli
that should
say from thomas morelli otherwise it
doesn't seem to make sense
thank you yeah we can we can amend that
with that change
do i have a proposal that i can now sign
the minutes councilor muller thank you
and a second to please
thank you councillor scarf
thank you we'll change that and they'll
sign the minutes later on
um but we
so uh we we need uh the electronic vote
on whether or not i should sign those
minutes
um so this is for accuracy having made
that change and could the governance
officer please conduct the electronic
vote
thank you chair i would just put in that
amendment as well
right thank you michelle the vote is now
in progress for members
um if you go to the modern.gov app and
go to the plus sign in the top right
hand corner then it will show the sub
section on attendance voting and on
there if you click on the light blue
colored one that shows the vote in
progress
um
councilman margaret mabry could i please
take your vote verbally please
i shall abstain i wasn't at the meeting
thank you thank you
thank you very much camper thank you
chair so all votes have now been
received and that is eight votes for and
one abstention thank you yes thank you
very much
um
have we received any petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme please none received chair thank
you
move on to item five
are there any questions from the public
none received yet thank you item six
any questions from councillors none
received yet thank you very much we're
now into the main item of the meeting
which is item
seven
which is the annual review of the joint
homes and housing strategy and homeless
and rough sleeping reduction strategy
in a minute i'll ask justin king to
present the report i'll then invite
questions on the presentation and the
report
then questions on the delivery plan and
the progress report
and then we'll debate the item so we'll
get all of the facts sorted before we
debate
but first i'd like to call on councillor
jan osborne to give her introduction as
cabinet member
thank you
thank you mr chairman
good morning i am delighted to introduce
to you for consideration and scrutiny
today the annual review of the joint
homes and housing strategy and the
homelessness reduction and rough
sleeping strategy 2019-2024
in march 2019 members of all political
parties unanimously approved the
adoption of the first joint homes and
housing strategy and joint homelessness
reduction and rough sleeping strategy
these strategies commit us to be open
and transparent providing information on
how we are performing against the
strategic aims set out within the
documents
so as part of adoption a commitment was
made to report back to overview and
scrutiny committee for an annual review
and update to members
this is the second annual review of the
progress made against these strategies
today i ask that the members review the
contents of this report and appendices
along with verbal contributions
scrutiny will be pleased to note that
there are no red flags in the action
plan and this is really good considering
the challenges that the housing team
have had to face over the last 18 months
justin king our housing needs and
standards manager who is the leader and
coordinator for the strategic housing
choice based lettings and private sector
teams is with us today and will now
provide you with a presentation which
shows the progress to date the actions
currently underway and the future action
planned over the remaining two and a
half years of the strategy thank you mr
chairman
thank you councillor osborne
over to you justin for your presentation
when it's up on the screen and when
you're oh your microphone is on
yes thank you thank you chair so we're
ready when you are thank you
good morning councillors and thank you
for the opportunity
to present to you today some of the
highlights of the work undertaken
in progress and planned to deliver
against these strategies
it was hoped to have francine tan here
today to deliver the presentation as she
has been instrumental in working with
colleagues to drive forward progress
she sends her apologies
so this annual review follows on from
the report that you received in
september twenty twenty
despite the covid19 pandemic
and the need to re-prioritize some of
the services within housing our offices
have continued to work hard to deliver
against these strategies
between 2020 and 2021
significant progress has been achieved
with the housing delivery action plan
that you can find at appendix 3 of the
report
with well over 100 actions i think you
can have confidence on the vast volume
of work that has taken place to deliver
actions to meet the aims within the
strategies
regular quarterly monitoring takes place
and contact with each of the action
leads to maintain that momentum
this table
on the slide highlights some of the
progress that has been made over the
last 12 months
so the homes and housing strategy does
contain a vast area of work including
all across multiple departments within
the council so some of the specifics
today i will try to answer some i may
need to take away
for a detailed answer from colleagues
the table on the previous slide is
summarized in this graph with the solid
blue line showing the progress that we
have made in
2021 and i'm pleased to say actions
experiencing delays has
decreased to zero
so we know that the homes and housing
strategy is made up of nine strategic
aims
over the next few slides i'm just going
to highlight some of the things that we
have delivered
are in progress and are still planned or
underway to continue delivery against
those
aims
for aim one i think the highlights have
has to be the delivery of new
affordable housing units and in
particular perhaps the
delivery of the former angel court care
home into 21 high quality social houses
within our planning service the
pre-application service we have been
undertaking work to survey our customers
and understand their requirements
and take forward actions to improve that
pre-application service
more recently we've seen an increase in
the number of pre-applications
187 in quarter 2
compared to 149
in the previous quarter
[Applause]
aim two
in the delivery of good quality housing
we've been undertaking some work to
review our garage stock and we've
identified 15 sites for the
for future potential development
we've also been working with community
led and community land trusts to be able
to support them for the delivery of
affordable housing
with our existing stock we are
continuing to input data
into our housing stock database and
we're 50 of the way
through that process
in the coming months we will be doing
some more work around our section 106
agreements to try and get some
consistency particularly around
the local people and the local
connection
with aim 3
this is a has a direct link to our joint
homelessness reduction and rough
sleeping strategy
as part of our goal to continue to
access funding streams for additional
support to tackle rough sleeping we have
been awarded approximately four hundred
and thirty thousand pounds worth of
funding
and this will be
some of this money will be utilized to
build five properties for rough sleepers
with high needs
ongoing we continue to inspect our
temporary accommodation three times per
week
aim four
with the delivery of our landlord
services we continue and have started
work with the tenant participation
advisory service and they've assisted us
in carrying out a review so that we are
ready for the changes that will be
coming in the social housing white paper
we've undertaken some work to find new
methods of communication including a new
monthly email bulletin which is now
reaching nearly 4 000 tenants
with our current stock we're also
working with the energy savings trust
to accurately predict
the environmental performance of our
properties so we can ascertain which
homes we need to carry out thermal
improvements to
over the coming months we are also
working on our housing revenue account
business plan and making sure that we
are ready for the next 30 years
with the business plan
aim 5
our community infrastructure levy has
been successfully spent
with work on four school extensions
three health facilities
and land for a fifth school extension
this is all linked to the work that's
contained within our infrastructure
delivery plan
and our funding statement plans as well
in progress
is some work around our car parks
and particularly the installation of
solar car ports
at station road sudbury and gainsborough
road in stone market
aim six
one of the definite and massive
highlights i think over the last year
has been a deli or the commencement of
our independent living service and the
delivery of our disabled facilities
grants this service has been brought
in-house and we are now successfully
spending the allocated disabled
facilities grants money that we receive
in addition we've been able to bring two
long-term empty homes back into use
and
distribute 23 landlord grants to improve
the heating systems in properties in the
private rented sector
we are currently bidding for some money
to carry out some enforcement on the
private rented sector landlords who may
be letting properties with an epc rating
of f and g
if that's successful that will initiate
some additional resources to tackle
those properties that are thermally
inefficient
through our suffolk central lettings we
have our landlord forum and we continue
to strengthen our links with the private
rented sector
aim seven
there's been a review of our housing
allocations policy and changes have been
approved
we continue to have a project group to
look at our short stay permanent and
permanent sites for gypsies romani and
travellers to meet their identified
needs various delivery plans across
all all of the teams are in place to
ensure delivery of other strategies
the suffolk housing board has recently
appointed a new coordinator
and that no that new coordinator can
take forward some specific areas of work
including that of understanding housing
needs of our older and vulnerable people
aim eight
we've completed our active well-being
programme in glensford i and holbrook
and great work is taking place
around the dementia action alliances in
other towns and villages
we continue to install heat pumps
across
our council-owned housing stock and
these are replacing some of the older
inefficient electric storage heating
systems
aim nine five neighborhood plans have
been adopted
uh and eleven
neighborhood plans have been adopted
and a further fifteen communities are
preparing for their amended plans as
well
we continue to have regular discussions
with holmes england
about the funding and sourcing of
funding to support the provision of
affordable housing by our registered
providers
sorry that was slide aim nine
so on this slide
this is to explain how our housing
strategy
links to the council's corporate plan
housing is one of our key strategic
priorities in the council's corporate
plan
so our strategic aims and action plan
seek to support and complement the other
strategies within the corporate plan
particularly the well-being and
communities strategy
so in september 2021 the strategies will
reach the midpoint of its proposed
five-year lifespan
the kovid 19 pandemic has contributed to
emerging policy considerations with more
focus on health and well-being
after a series of workshops that have
been conducted recently
housing issues have been identified and
therefore we believe that these
strategies will benefit in the future
from promoting actions to tackle
identified issues
such as greater investment in
sustainable homes
more emphasis on habitats and
biodiversity
consideration to the social housing
white paper and planned changes
and the development of our hra business
plan
i hope from this report and presentation
members are assured that we are
delivering and adapting the housing
delivery plan to meet new requirements
new and current challenges and deliver
against those aims
thank you chad
thank you very much justin
um yeah there's a lot going on um yes
with nine strategic aims and about a
hundred action points i can see there is
a lot of work to do and so i'm going to
invite i've got councillor first i'm
inviting people to ask questions on the
report and the presentation so
councillor muller please thank you chair
first of all justin thank you very much
for that excellent presentation that was
really interesting just a couple of
questions actually um
you mentioned about the garages and that
um they're gonna be some redevelopment
proposed for those for those tenants
that currently hire those garages are
sort of are there other plans for those
tenants to be able to park their
vehicles elsewhere being proposed
if any scheme that uh has a garage that
is occupied
and
planned redevelopment takes place there
will definitely be full consultation
with anybody occupying a garage
and alternative solutions worked and
considered for that particular customer
definitely thank you my second question
if i may chair is that you mentioned
about some five properties for rough
sleepers which i think is really
excellent that's the right way to go
um will these be similar to those i
think it's proposed by ipswich barrow
council where they've converted shipping
containers to house
rough sleepers is that a similar thing
that you were thinking about
the
i believe these are going to be new
modular units right but they are not
shipping containers that have been used
by other local authorities there are a
variety of options out there
available to be
to used
for new temporary accommodation
the exact modular home that we are
proposing i don't know but i can take
away to find out for you okay thank you
very much thank you chad thank you
councillors is next
thank you very much
thank you very much
excellent report justin um firstly um
how you set up the lease so quickly in
sudbury
i think the time span where that was
sorted was amazing
so that was good you didn't meant but i
think that should be highlighted
recently how you've homed
someone and um again that was brilliant
um and also about the the gypsy travel
liaison because i chair
the sub group maybe
we could get together with your officers
because i think maybe
um as i wanted to and we wanted to from
the group from the gypsy and traveller
group
to maybe have some sort of training for
other councillors to understand the
difficulties and problems with gypsies
and travelers as well when it's not in
my field sort of thing but um so i'd
like to help with that if we if we could
and so that was very good and and the
other thing is the officer who
frequently
walks the meadows at sudbury and around
there looking for the homeless people
there's so many people
at ground level that do so much work so
thank you
thank you and in response to the uh
gypsy and romani travelers then we can
definitely take that forward through
that working party and develop a
training as required
thank you
uh councillor carter i have next
yes thank you
again excellent report might so follow
his pursuit and everyone else saying
that um
in the air report
in papers
uh mentions here regarding how the uh on
the annual basis three-year pipeline um
of the new council development
acquisitions with the section 106
spending
um with
faber they have um
spent well
purchased um
uh
so i say i'm
trying to read my own nights without me
glasses it always helps doesn't it yes
sorry
um
mid suffolk 436 and 106 extinctions
um
which is 71 less than baber
i'm trying to work out is this due to a
difference in priorities between the
mid-suffolk and baber or is it a
difference in
availability that we've had between the
two but why are we uh why have mid sub
expenses but favoring this
the
i think the supply of new affordable
housing is not an exact science that you
can probably put numbers in each year um
what may be more helpful within the
report for us to include in the future
is
an average number
over a two to five year period because
that will probably give better
representation of the numbers
and
i also said the
question we've gone um
on the on page 39 regards the internet
supply for um for our
tenants
uh would that be including
would that include
offering advice
for
for
supplies or would it be a
incentive to suspect suppliers to
actually might be able to if we approach
suppliers and see whether or not they'd
be willing to offer a deal to our
tenancy we might be we might be able to
offer better internet connection to our
tenants
yeah she said it's on page 39 uh yes
page 39 the july uh june july
um regarding internet usage
uh for our tendency
uh sorry is that have you got the number
of the action oh number four please
sorry yes i'm with you now
could i take that question away i can
come back to you and consult with the
action lead for that particular action
to find out specifically thank you thank
you final question regarding the
rough sleeping um
will we be working with partners should
be um the rough sleeper have any uh
accessibility issues
will these modular units be fully
wheelchair accessible
and if they if the rough sleeper
happens to
require more medical supplies that they
currently may have
how will we be reaching out to our
partner organizations or will it be left
to the until they find further housing
needs before they can
have any
help with the adaptations or
equipment
the
there's def different levels of
accessibility through the planning
process
for access i don't know specifically
what level
is planned for these new units
what i do can definitely confirm is that
we would work with any individual user
to meet any accessibility needs to make
sure
that they had adequate adequate housing
that met their needs
thank you very much
thank you councillor osborne i think you
had a question or a point to make please
just to
rewind back to the question about the
acquisitions of homes for our housing
stock it can vary from months to months
so you might find that baber has a an
increase mid suffix
goes down and then the following month
mid suffix will go up i think also you
need to bear in mind that actually mid
suffix hra housing revenue account isn't
as healthy as babies so we can possibly
spend a bit more on acquisitions and
perhaps midsuffocone at this particular
point in time
thank you
yeah i've got one or two questions on
the the supply of affordable homes if i
may
do we know how many for each district we
need of social rent affordable rent and
shared ownership
um i mean are we are we on on the target
and do we have sufficient housing units
to ensure that there'll be no
homelessness or rough sleeping
and
also so i'm going on a bit and also
to reduce the amount of time that
families or individuals spend in bed and
breakfast
can i answer plea please do yeah yeah
in terms of the affordable housing
supply yes we do have numbers and i
think that's contained within documents
within the joint local plan for each
council
how many units for temporary
accommodation
predicting the the supply is very very
difficult i think looking back over the
last 12 months how we've responded to
everybody everyone in
the need to be able to house
temporarily everybody to source
accommodation when we have peak demand
we're very flexible and adaptable to how
we use our accommodation to meet those
needs
so i think we'll always keep that
under review
to make sure that we can meet that
future demand
um if i could just come back and
approach you can answer this this point
as well uh and that is that the
the draft joint local plan was published
before
the kobe pandemic and i think in terms
of housing a lot has changed in housing
and the need perhaps the need for social
rent or affordable rent is is there any
proposal to review the number of
affordable units
and
rented rented units
as a result of the pandemic
um
comparing it to the number in the joint
local plan
councillor
osborne rewind back to your your first
question the the one way that we uh
monitor need is obviously is by the
housing register and the number that's
on there and the type of properties that
they need so that's one mechanism for
doing that um in regards to um will we
ever be able to house everybody in
we would love to have a magic wand um
but i think that's going to be an
impossible task moving forward but we
will do our utmost to ensure that people
that haven't got a home is absolutely
limited and that includes rough sleepers
and those that are so for surfing as
well
i think
in regards to temporary housing that's
an ongoing thing on week to week that's
constantly being reviewed by officers on
the need because there's no way that we
want to
uh provide temporary housing if we find
in six months time we're going to have
those standing empty when there's people
that need permanent accommodation so
that's constantly being reviewed on the
the need for temporary accommodation
so i hope that answers some of you yeah
thank you
do i have any uh cancer scarf
yes thank you chair um
yes congratulations on the steady
progress that you're making as a team uh
on these action points um but just a
general point there are
one or two in the action points within
the program here where they have dates
which have actually passed but the
narrative tells a different story
so i
would appreciate if
some of the things you're still to scope
in terms of whether you're going to
actually do them or not and they require
further information but i wonder if we
could have
as an outcome from today
a reassessment of the dates within the
report to ensure that they accurately
reflect
achievable time scales because when
reviewing anything as a committee it's
very difficult obviously if the dates
already passed but you can see in the
narrative the work is ongoing so perhaps
some of them need ongoing within them
rather than date specifics or and some
of them may well need date specifics in
order to ensure that they're done in a
timely fashion and you know concentrate
priorities on
i think if i could
just explain i think
the
the delivery plan is at as at june or
july of this year and then through the
committee process is the presentation uh
today as you say some of those dates are
now out of date and there could be an
update there certainly will be another
annual review take place
for september
next year
would it be helpful to have a
an interim update
i guess is what
you're asking for is it
uh on some of the specifics perhaps yes
where where they fall into that category
where i've just sort of uh elaborated
because
the narrative does tell a different
story uh and one or two of the
action points are dependent on other
outcomes uh that the council is doing
um i do have a specific other question
chair as well if i may please yes
item 3.13 talks about us building a
relationship with local citizens advice
to agree a protocol for joined up
working to support individuals and
families experiencing complex housing
difficulties and the narrative tells us
that that
work is currently being planned and a
meeting is planned with colleagues from
citizens advice to determine the next
steps for this action
um
as a local member in stone market i had
quite a lot of contact with citizens
advice
and
i am aware that there are actually
issues
with that
in terms of
the housing solutions team and its
interaction with citizens advice
and i'm concerned i think that
that level of interaction has
deteriorated
over recent times and we really need to
take some action to ensure that we get
that back again because
citizens advice are often the first port
of call for
tenants uh with
problems with housing
and provide a wonderful service in terms
of helping those tenants and
they are perhaps diverted to citizens
advice in the first case rather than
housing solutions
so there is i think a desperate need
there for
a better working relationship because i
am aware that the working relationship
is not where it should be at this moment
in time
there's useful feedback and i agree with
you our relationship with the citizens
advice bureau
is is vitally important
so
we will certainly take that away and
make uh sure that we do follow up with
stone market citizens device bureau and
we
re-prioritize that action to make sure
that our work with all of the citizens
advice bureaus is progressing
uh as we would expect it to thank you
yeah if i can support that it is it is
vital because quite often citizens
advice will be dealing with other
difficulties of a particular family it's
not you know housing may be the first
that family's first concern but quite
often
if housing and citizens advice are
working together
with a particular individual family
other things will come to light there
will be other problems and and
sort of a holistic
solution is probably what's best and the
only way to do that really is
working very closely together i think
that uh yeah i would support exactly
what uh councillor scarf has said
um
sorry counselor i was born yeah thank
you mr chairman um i can't speak for the
relationship
between mid suffolk and stone market but
the one at sudbury um and i just say i'm
a trustee on the cob
has got a really good working
relationship and speaking to the manager
of the subgroup branch and she is very
happy with the relationship we've got
however there is always room for
improvement so i would suggest that
perhaps we could look at the model that
we've got in sudbury
compare it to the one in stone market to
see if there's some good points that we
pick up on and we may even be able to
pick up some points from stone market to
put into a practice for the uh the
sudbury one thank you mr chairman thank
you very much
uh councillor being your own we've got
your next and then counselor dawson
thank you chair um i have a couple of
questions
uh
i mean i do agree with other counsellors
that this is an extensive and useful
report
but i am actually from a management
point of view
rather concerned by the large number of
actions
um
and and the management of them because i
noticed that actually of the 92 actions
38 of them are ongoing
and when i review some of those actions
it seems to me that they are actually
part and parcel of the work of the
department and i'm not sure um
entirely how useful they are to be
documented in the way that they are
being documented here
um
and you know i think um
you know i'd like to see a
shorter
more concise set of actions really in
relation to the work that the department
is doing uh which and i would agree with
councillor scarf about the the
timeliness of those actions um
and in fact there are some actions that
clearly
i would think would would be completed
well before the um the end dates that
are being suggested due to the nature of
those actions
um so i would urge a comprehensive
review of this list um in in the very
near future um because i think that
there are
uh elements of it that leave a lot to be
desired um i'd like to go to item 1.8
of
the actions which is related to
affordable housing
and i'm just wondering
why we're not able to quantify the
potential number of affordable housing
units based on the
planning applications that have been
approved that are that would qualify to
to be putting forward affordable housing
and there and therefore i then
understand what we need to be doing to
cheer you up the developers to deliver
on those that's my first question in
that section then i think in a sense
related is uh item 1.14
um
which relates to self and custom build
and i believe you know you're looking at
some garage locations to do that but
i'm just wondering whether when you talk
about self-build are these for people to
build
and live in their own homes or what
would be the conditions be attached to
that
issue
and then finally in 1.10
um
we you're looking to keep evidence on
stalled sites and update those on an
ongoing basis
um
i guess quite frankly what to know how
many stall sites we've got and and you
know what the situation may or may not
be with regard to to all of those um so
if you could address that i really
appreciate it
thank you councillor um i think you're
right in terms of the
actions that we've got identified as
ongoing that two or three years ago
they've now moved on and they have
become business as usual within the
delivery of
specific teams so perhaps we need to now
find a new way of showing those as
business as usual work and
effectively completed actions uh for the
for a future
in terms of the 1.8 and the timing of
properties being delivered
any potential development site
can take two three sometimes longer
years to
see it actually come out of the ground
and be delivered
which makes it very hard i think to
predict
the
with preciseness the timings of of
supply
in 1.14 this i know we do maintain a
self build register which i think that
action uh refers to
with regards
um stalled sites could i take that
action that question away to liaise with
the action lead and come back to you
please
thank you counselor pyongyang
if i could just come back on
uh
mr king's response with regard to the
affordable
element i mean
it's my understanding that the the sites
that qualify
would have a number of affordable homes
attached to them so i think that that's
my point what what is that figure and
then
you know what is the timeline for their
delivery
again i think that's something i need to
take away and explore with the action
lead as to the feasibility of being able
to predict and plan in that way i
wouldn't like to say if it's possible or
not
thank you
yeah that's almost in parallel with the
stored sites because some of the some of
the
some of the
affordable units are held up with delays
either a stalled site or a slow
development of the site so yeah i think
that's probably something for
planning officers to have a look at and
to come back to us with
thank you um who have i got next uh
councillor dawson
so thank you very much your uh that's
excellent your talk
um it's very informative and i must say
you know hadley we're absolutely
delighted with what you've done there
it's taken seven years i think but it's
it's fantastic really is
fantastic development um but what i'd
just like to one of the things um i i'm
wondering is why on 2.1 the the reviews
for such an important portfolio are
going to be instead of biannually going
to be annually and i find that a bit
disturbing because you know the assets
are such a big part of our portfolio
and i would rather i think it's very
important this recommend you know this
takes place by annually furthermore
as a counselor um you know this isn't
communicated to us in any way at all so
i have to be honest
my second question i was coming on to is
you know i have no idea actually how
many
uh
it was it didn't really come out to me
in this
how how large our portfolio is and
you've got several people buying these
houses so we're set i mean i know that
we've got 21 houses in hadley
but how many in baber and i'm sure
likewise in mid suffolk have they sold
so i can't sort of get my head round
really whether we've got an excess
or a deficit of the housing supply and
it seems to me the most important thing
i i always i've asked this a number of
times before
um i think there's something that i
can't somewhere we don't have a monthly
update on the housing portfolio and
someone mentioned to me by accident when
i was at hadley
that apparently there might be another
50 houses coming up and housing stock at
september and she said she'd get back to
me never did
so i'm sure a number of the members like
myself really
we need a running tally on this what's
being sold
what is being actually built because 21
here or there that's great for us but
actually that's seven years it's taken
us to get there
and i i i've got no idea um with this
paper
what the deficit or surplus is
and how many of those are actually going
to people rough sleepers because i
understood that we had no rough sleepers
particularly in hadley
so this is
this housing portfolio is just a general
isn't it
so to come could i just clarify you
mentioned 2.1
is that in the action delivery
in your um or is it the actual main
report in the main report here the
purpose of the report
options to be considered and one of them
is to have an annual review rather than
twice yearly
um i'm surprised twice a year isn't it
enough actually
the
so to just respond to the various points
firstly in terms of hadley and the
delivery of angel court um i don't want
to take any credit for that because i've
only joined uh baber mid suffolk in the
last six months so i will pass that on
to colleagues that have
worked extensively hard
over the last few years for the delivery
of that scheme so thank you
in terms of 2.1
the
that relates to an annual review of this
homes and housing strategy
uh where
it's been recommended and decided that
an annual review of the strategy
in but why sorry
i
would imagine that's the recommendation
was it from a previous committee for an
annual review
i think
when i look back at last year's report
it was suggested for an annual review
of the homes and housing strategy
is that yeah i mean i just my
recommendation would be
it just seems very peculiar it's not
more often
i think that
overview and scrutiny last year decided
they would
like to review
the whole of the strategy or progress on
meeting the strategy 12 months ago
so that's
that is the reason that it's here today
i think what um you may be suggesting
councillor dawson is that there are some
aspects of the strategy strategy which
need to be reviewed more often
i certainly do yes i mean you know with
these sort of strategic reviews of large
portfolios they're sort of done weekly
monthly but i don't i'm surprised it's
twice yearly um but it's just something
that i would be thinking if this was my
portfolio
i would really want to be on the ball
with this and i'd want to be
communicating to my fellow counselors
and if there's only an annual review and
certainly people like myself
i don't really know what's going on with
this portfolio
can we park that for a little while
until we come on to the sort of main
thrust of the debate and moving towards
your accommodations this is an option to
be considered it says here and i think
we should consider
that you know to recommend it remains as
a minimum twice a year the if you didn't
mind is that right that would be fine
let's let's let's bring that back when
we're looking at recommendations yeah we
we don't these are just suggested
recommendations they're not the
recommendations that we're necessarily
going to put two cabinet and tickets now
i realized that
thank you did you have anything else
council barrett
uh dawson sorry yes it was about
next sorry yeah so it's about the
numbers of the you know the surplus and
deficit uh really
um i think you alluded this to yourself
councillor wellington and council
epineur
um
the capacity is it increasing or is it
decreasing of the overall capacity there
we've got a surplus or we've got a
deficit i i just don't know and i don't
really know how many there are in the
portfolio
to be exact
right can i take councillor morley
please if you're going to attempt to
answer some of these questions up some
of these points
i might be able to assist a little bit
in as much as the acquisition of housing
units for the hra comes under the assets
and investments portfolio
and whilst i'm not the assets investment
portfolio holder i do have a little bit
of of knowledge about this and i can
tell you that there's
214
a target of 214 to be added to baba
and a total of 200 new council homes
being added for mid suffolk so perhaps i
could suggest that you invite the assets
and investment assistant directors
perhaps to your next meeting who uh may
be able to give you more details on that
yeah yeah i can confirm those numbers
are are in uh are in the action plan but
we we don't have a clue as to
how how far we've got along
the the track of that
and if it is in the housing strategy
it's
that the housing strategy has has
actions for
um uh offices around the other other
departments we've got um
uh
various um action leads within the
document um i think
what we would have liked to have seen
probably was um
some progress on all of the actions no
matter who the action lead is
um but i'll go to councillor osborne now
of things on this one first of all in
regards to the market homes i can't
answer that it's not my portfolio but
those that come forward on our
developments for affordable homes
there's a waiting list for them the ones
that angel court for example went in
less than a week so there's definitely a
need there and more are more definitely
required in regards to the the reporting
as you've already alluded to mr chairman
this recommendation came from scrutiny
meeting so that's why that's been put
forward as annually
it's the portfolio i have monthly
meetings and i this is always part of
that monthly meeting there's a report to
me and we go through the actions where
there's a delay um it's um
where there's progress et cetera et
cetera so that is done on a regular
basis if there's going to be an impact
in a particular ward i'd ask that that
ward member be advised and i get the cc
of those emails so i see that those ward
members are advised for example the ward
members in hadley were kept up to date
on the progress of
of angel court and were indeed invited
to the handover of the keys that we had
in regards to the progress of
deliverable homes affordable homes
that's done every quarter in the
monitoring report and that goes to all
members not just cabinet members that
goes to all members
but if there's members feel that that
could be reported in a different way a
more effective way all they need to do
is let myself know and my housing team
and we'll look to see if we can report
it differently um in regards to baber um
it was 214 as sue's already alluded to
we're already on target to deliver more
than that we've already delivered 130 of
that and only in september there was 21
angel court 24 waldenfield road eight in
shockley and romans way i haven't got
the number for that but acton are coming
forward as well so there's a lot coming
forward but that is in the monitoring
report every quarter thank you yeah
thank you
did you have any other questions
counselor dawson
i'm back on the right homeless
uh
ness reduction
i mean does this mean then that we've
got so many coming forward we haven't
sold very many and therefore we have a
well we've got a surplus
i'm still not it's not clear is it this
is
i don't know if i'm being bit steep in
here is this some social are you talking
about social housing units this is a
housing strategy and about homelessness
reduction
and if we've got 240 being added
now i'm sure many of these how our
housing stock as in mid-south are being
sold
so
do we have a surplus of housing
therefore we can house
you know a lot of these people we don't
have homelessness or if we've got a
deficit in which case some of our action
points will need to be perhaps
changed i don't know because the numbers
aren't here
i think the indication that we've
received is that
there are there are more people asking
for an affordable home than there are
homes so and i think
even if the number of affordable homes
available increased so the number of
people wanting them would increase
um
so it's it's not as if it's a target
that's
fixed in
time and is going to be met at that date
because the target will forever be going
be going up
um so
uh but i mean you're right we need to we
need to have that data or members need
to have that data i think the indication
is from the cabinet member that that
data is available
um
quarterly and perhaps is available
categorize more to you more often than
quarterly i don't know um but if there
are if there is other other data
required or if there's other data
available let's see if the the need is
met by the data that is available
but i think that's something we can look
at outside to make sure that we're we
have got the information we need
um i'll cancel ourselves you want to
come back on that i've then got
councillor barrett i've got councillor
carter
sorry yeah
sort of taking us in order and i seem to
be missed out
thank you
um
i've got you on the list um
did you did you did you have something
else you wanted to say councillor a
quick one thank you mr chairman
obviously as cabinet member i get that
information but if other members want
that information they only have to email
me and i can provide it to them as and
when they request
it you very much so i'm going to take
councillor barrett and then councilman
i'm sorry if i'm going out of order
i'm a bee someone high up the list
margaret
um
i thank you for the the uh report and
it's the first time i've seen that
housing delivery um
sort of report so it's good to see
the
sort of um loftier aims translated into
actions uh that are
you know deliverable and more
understandable and also to see uh lead
action leads names against each of those
actions
does that then
translate into performance targets for
each of those people named so that they
are
you know held to account over each of
those areas
because i think that really helps to see
delivery on actions
and thank you councillor and and partly
links to
uh councillor dawson's question around
the ongoing work for monitoring delivery
of this uh
of those action plans
the action plan we have a dedicated
officer that spends a majority of their
time working through with colleagues to
make sure that these actions are
delivered so those action leads this
work is very much
part of their workload
as we touched upon earlier it's almost
become business as usual
now for some of these
action leads it's their daily work so it
would feature in their objective
settings
for their work definitely yes
okay and and so those performance
reviews
with the line manager
take place yes every three months or in
line with our our policy around uh
one-to-ones objectives annual reviews uh
so i'm sure those discussions do take
place okay driving those forward okay
thank you
thank you any other questions
counselor maybe i'm sorry if i missed
you before
thank you thank you mr chairman and um
i'm going to say to mr king welcome
because it's the first time i've met you
face to face so it's nice to meet you
thank you nice to meet you too thank you
um
i'm going to be controversial at the end
and everyone here is going to absolutely
hate me and probably some of the public
but i'm going to say something at the
end
but first but first of all
i do have lots of questions um about the
report if i can take you to 1.6 on page
15 where you're talking about
new ways of living
the one item you have not mentioned is
the actual immunity space of someone's
home
there is a comment further through the
report about community open space etc
however
i'm mentioning this because i
recently
viewed a new property
and i could not believe how tiny the
outdoor space was when it was supposed
to be for a family
if you've got two children two adults in
there
that was it
and i really do think that we miss
something here
it may well be
from
looking at planning applications that
developers are trying to put
forward more properties per
acre hectare however one would like to
look at it and i think that's something
that baber district council in
particular and probably mid-southwest
should be more careful about
um so that's that's my first um i've
annotated all the paperwork so i will be
turning over pages
would it be helpful for me to answer
that first point yes if you wish yes
thank you
thank you councillor the
i am aware that we do
uh through the planning process have
minimum space stats but space standards
for uh new build properties so our
properties will meet those minimum
standards
as you mentioned and allude to sometimes
they are
very small but they do meet the minimum
standard there is a
draft
design specification for
new build council developments and that
very much does acknowledge the need to
maximize where we can
outdoor immunity space and alluded to in
my presentation around
health and well-being
and biodiversity we need to make sure
that we address
that where we can in future developments
to maximize the available space okay i'm
going to come back to you perhaps
perhaps you misunderstood what i i meant
this is private immunity space i.e
within the fencing of a property
because it's all very well having
immunity space outside and there are
some lovely new play areas for children
that i know that have come forward
however as a mother of four and a granny
of four i'm absolutely horrified that
these play areas are next to suds basins
which are not fenced off because it's
it's deemed that they're safer not
fenced off than fenced
because if you turn your back on a small
child
they can move quicker than you can
and you may be distracted
and then there is a tragedy coming
forward i am talking about when a
property is built it should have it
should have proper
secure immunity space for that property
to allow children to be playing outside
without the need for those children or
the district council or developers or
whoever to expect that amenity sites are
all play areas for all children so
that's what i'm talking about and
nowhere have i seen that you've
mentioned that in this report
could i just interject i think that's
probably a planning matter rather than a
a district well i'm going to come on to
that because actually i think some of
this report does
step over into planning because we're
also talking about
um and i'm going i've got loads of
questions mr chairman because you're
also talking about pre-application
advice well that actually is a planning
matter so why is it in here
and from experience
our pre-application advice does not work
yeah um but i'm just getting a bit
concerned
we're trying to ask
somebody in the housing service to
answer questions on on on planning
issues
but mr mr chairman what i've actually
said and i'm sorry but mr king took it
more forward
is i actually said that nowhere in this
does it actually mention
that
housing
includes looking at the private immunity
space because it says on 1.6
particularly in the housing sector new
ways of living have emerged and the
measing of housing has changed
significantly well during covered it has
and people need their own private
outdoor space as well and that is what
i'm arguing i can move on
i'm happy to move on yeah
if you would we'll take we'll take note
of that and there are there are probably
matters here to refer to planning
officers
there's several
thank you um under five 5.1 item one
the housing market functions effectively
i'm sorry that's a that's a sweeping
statement
and
i would ask for your qualification on
that please
is that 5.1 of the action plan
page 16 i'm still on your report thank
you
uh so if i could just clarify these are
the aims from our homes and housing
strategy so this is what we're aiming to
achieve
in the strategy
but it's a sweet it's a sweeping
statement and i think we ought to be
careful about sweeping statements as
with following on
item
five under that as well homes are in
high quality sustainable environments
served by jobs and community facilities
in my own village where i live where i'm
a district councillor the big issue at
the moment is houses are being built but
there are no jobs
everyone has to drive there
and
i'm then
just check
counselor maybe i i agree with you that
at the top of page 17 the statement
homes are in high quality sustainable
environments and so on um
that uh
we might well have an opinion that that
that act that action that target is not
met but i think that is a matter to take
back to planning officers which i think
we should do
and
i understood that overview of scrutiny
covers all all points so thank you for
that
um so i'm going to
return to your presentation which was um
on this on the screen thank you
there's a comment about clts
um and that these are being met
with information um
i totally disagree
the one that obviously i work with is
lavenham
and they have had severe issues about
getting
the funding for future projects
and i can take this up with you later
you mentioned that i think you said
seven i'm not i'm not going to keep
turning pages um could you identify
where they are or would it not have been
helpful for us all to have known where
they are
please
bear with me
they may be listed within
the
action plan
if you're happy for me just to try and
locate that
i recall seeing the number but i don't
recall seeing the actual parents and
they and it would it would be useful
well i think that's something which we
can have the information on
if if justin you could take that away
okay thank you very much
um we're also talk you were also talking
about air source heat pumps um i have
one on my own property i think i'm a
trail brake blazer for
for the council as a councillor for that
um
but we don't you don't actually mention
if these are in new properties or
whether they have been retrofitted in
older properties
uh in relation to those numbers they are
retrofitted they are retrofitted
can we place a
either an oil or gas boiler
okay thank you and could i or could the
council also know or this committee know
are they properties of a substantial age
or are they fairly new because air
source heat pumps work very effectively
but they do need really good insulation
in a property
yes as part of the decision making to
replace with an s source heat pump we do
need to look at the overall thermal
efficiency of a property
to make sure that it is adequate and
supports the use of a heat pump so that
does take place
in when deciding whether to replace
with a heat pump i think i'm right that
there's a pro a pilot project well
probably more than one but one in
particular in one house that that there
will be there'll be some learning from
that and perhaps
when when we have some information that
we can feed back then perhaps um that
that could be done in some in some
fashion thank you thank you very much um
following on from that um you're talking
about landlords and they
they
can apply for a grant for heating
systems
i thought by law
that all landlords had to provide
proper central effective central heating
under a certain
i don't know what you call it
under a certain
parameter um i thought it was by this
year 2021
there is
potential for what you might call a
category one hazard if a landlord is
renting a property without a effective
heating system
often those grants have been issued in
response to allow landlords to improve
the heating system in those properties
and also touched upon within the
presentation was the
funding that we we have applied for to
take action against landlords private
rented landlords who are renting out
properties
with an f and a g epc rating so that we
can take action okay uh to improve the
thermal efficiency of those properties
as well that again may result in that
landlord applying to us for a grant if
they are eligible for funding to carry
out improvement works thank you
now i'm going to move on to
the part about sill paying for
school
extensions this is a joint report
i totally agree but it would be good for
the committee to actually understand
where these extensions are being built
in which areas are they all in
mid-suffolk are they all in baber i have
no idea
i'm unable to answer that question
specifically i'd have to take it away to
get that thank you extra detail for you
they are all in the infrastruc
infrastructure delivery plan
so there is a document that lists them
all thank you but i probably have not
read that thank you very much i've been
on holiday
um
i
acknowledge that you have this
tenant forum which is which is very very
good
i am a bit concerned that
um 500 tenants replied out of how many
um and that 42 were very satisfied with
repairs but what the other 58
and i have experienced that very of
having to
be very firm with um
with the maintenance teams to actually
get some repairs done within my
within my ward so
that is of concern you don't i don't
think you have to comment if you wish
you do and then i'll come to my
controversial bit
and i know this is controversial and i
know everyone's going to look at me and
say what
but i think we are all digging ourselves
into a very big hole with affordable
housing and i'll explain why
on one side of the equation we have
those who are in desperate need of a
home i acknowledge that absolutely
however you
i would suggest
that colleagues and officers actually
try talking to younger people and i'm
going to say between the ages of 20 and
30 for example
to see what they say
because if these people are desperate
for a home of their own and they are
only just slightly out of
the need for an affordable
they can't get one
and there is beginning to become
some imbalance
controversy
and
blatant jealousy that some people can
apply for an affordable home and get one
and others cannot
those that apply for an affordable home
and this is the question for you is if
they have an affordable home
how many years is it before they can buy
that house and then profit from it and
this is the imbalance that we are
getting and we are digging ourselves
into a big hole
because as councillor osborne said there
is more and more need for affordable
housing
and
i am just flagging up now
that
it may well be a symptom of our society
when we do not treat
absolutely everyone fairly
without discrimination as to what their
situation is
i have had someone recently say to me
i had to save i had to work hard to buy
my house and i still struggle to pay for
it
however
somebody else
and thankfully they don't always mention
the names to me
has just said
well i gave up my job and i got an
affordable house
now i know this is controversial and
everyone's situation is different but
baber and i'm going to suggest mid
suffolk are digging our hat selves into
a bigger and bigger hole that we need
more affordable
was there a question there please there
is
no i'm not talking about government
policy
i am just
mentioning this because we are being
told that we
somewhere in here i think it was 111
that we're hoping to build councillor
osborne i think said we've got 130 odd
and i know within my own ward my own
village we have more and more developers
coming and we are putting forward
further more and more affordable housing
the question is
are we
going to
be overrun by requests for affordable
housing
which then makes our housing policy
and all these strategies absolutely
obsolete thank you mr chairman
i don't think that's a question that
that could be answered off the cuff here
i think that there's
there's
so much in that question that i think
we're going to have to take that away
um cancer osborne
you're right mr chairman it's not a
question for today a lot of it is down
to government policy and our hands are
timed by government policy we have to
abide by it however what i will say is
there is a band in process so everybody
that puts in an application is banded on
based on their circumstances and their
needs and that includes financial
situation as well um but that i think
that's a question away from this
particular forum
yeah yes i i i
don't really want to labor the point but
i think the suggestion is that
one could make oneself look worse off
and and in the end you're better off
because you get you you can in due
course get the home that you wanted at a
cheaper price but that's not something
for today i think that's something that
is well worth officers looking at at
some point but i don't think there's
much much we can say about that today
unless you're desperate to
only uh mr chairman to add the and
follow on from council osborne's point
that we have an allocations policy
that has been agreed that
assesses everybody's individual
application and their circumstances to
ensure fairness in the allocation of the
housing stock thank you very much
uh councillor carter i think i had you
next and councillor ek penyong after
councillor carter
yes i'm going against uh
advice here
i should probably uh i'm going to
declare that i am actually a counselor
in a council home
and
i can attest here how the importance of
the
um
citizen advice because it's
thanks to students advice
that i actually ended up in a council
home after seven years of trying
with a disability so i can attest how
difficult it is
to get a property
yes how easy is for other people
i wanted to go back to
rough sleeping and
apparently we don't have but
if you look around there are still a
growing number of rough sleepers
and
i'm trying to work out where these
statistics for the reduction of them is
coming
because when i talk to them because i'm
one of the people who do
it turns out i'm one of a few people to
actually approach rough sleepers to talk
to them as
it turns out either myself or maybe
another counsellor may do but no one
else approaches him
and i'm trying to work out where this is
is it based on only by people who's been
reported by people doing reporting or by
observations or by people who actually
have seen these rough sleepers
um
why is it that it's only a few people
that are approaching visa rafts
are we employing people to go out there
to
search for our sleepers and approach
them
is it being left to just help the public
to actually do it
and if it's down to a public
why are say
people approaching it
is there more that we could be doing via
advertising the number for contacts for
if you have a
if you see a rough sleeper is there more
we could be doing with public outreach
regarding rough sleeping
um
and is it possible we may need to look
at the
employment uh people or translators
because some of the rusting which i've
spoken to
i'm lucky in fact that i do speak some
bulgarian and some
um
basic slavic language
um which
um some travelers do
speak to and they haven't understood
when people spoke to them do we need to
employ somebody who speaks more than one
language to
approach these people
um
regards that
um
would it be helpful just for me to uh
because we do have a dedicated team who
are very very responsive to uh
individual reports of rough sleeping and
are quickly out there same day within
hours often to engage with the rough
sleepers who provide
support and advice that is a very
effective service that we provide
care
is beneficial in terms of preventing
further problems and often gets them the
support that they need to get them
either
into temporary accommodation or the
support services that they need
we can
publicize there is a dedicated email
address
and contact number for counsellors
members of the public to report rough
sleeping so that we can uh respond
straight away so we'll make sure that
you've got that
those details yes i've got those and
there's a it's thanks to
i can attest that after reporting them
it has been very quick i'm just trying
to work out why
so if you if they might have been out
there for several weeks before someone
had breached it
why it's just
why it's only
down to somebody like me and why aren't
more people approaching it why aren't we
saying
giving a bit more giving more of a push
maybe on
uh
on the bbc radio things like
to actually do a drive for saying
statistically
rough's open slow but you've got a pair
of eyes on you why not do something
about it and try to help somebody else
because i think it's a stigma and a lot
of fear down to coven as well why you
wouldn't want to approach somebody
but
we are all people we need to do more on
this yeah yeah can we yeah i mean i
think there's a question in there
somewhere i think there's something to
take away
um
i mean we also have to bear in mind
somebody who does speak to rough sleep
but some of them actually prefer to be
rough sleepers
some people who just don't want
to have the responsibility of a home
to to keep up
council osborne and then i'm going on to
councillor egg pinyon
thank you
yeah it's very fair to say that a lot of
rough sleepers have very diverse needs
and it really calls and draws on the
skills of our homelessness team and and
they do accommodate that and they have
got obviously contacts there where they
can go just recently we were awarded
funding to enable us to recruit a um
mental health worker
so that that person can relate to those
people who have got mental health
problems obviously it's a bit difficult
to recruit because the mental health
services are finding it but they're
short staffed anyway but we have got
funding to do that and in regards to
rough sleepers i think it's right to say
that where are rough sleepers wants us
to engage with them we will do that and
we will do it very very quickly
obviously counsellors members of the
public
are the council's ears and eyes in a lot
of cases
that was very recent with a rough
sleeper that we had in sudbury
um but
we must appreciate that a lot of those
rough sleepers don't want to be engaged
with they want to to keep as you've
alluded to as to chairman they want to
retain that way of living but if they
don't then we're there and even if they
do of opinion where they don't want to
engage with us we don't give up on them
we still visit them on a regular basis
to try and resolve their problems
um but we you know the work that's being
done with russ sleepers excuse me
it's immense
and uh it's really really coming on and
as i say there'll be a review of the
temporary accommodation to see where we
can provide more houses for rough
sleepers there's a great deal of work
being done there including the breakdown
of possibly languages as well
thank you very much i've got councillor
ek pinyong then
when when we've heard from council hey
peony on can we start to think about
what recommendations we would be likely
to make
two offices to cabinet or to council
thank you
thank you mr chairman uh first of all
i'd like to uh completely endorse the
comments of mr king and councillor
osborne with regards to rough sleepers
um in my experience and i i do engage
with them uh obviously i'm no
expert but i engage them as one human to
another and i have had
report the chance to report that to the
the uh the department concern and i
think the uh the response has been more
than acceptable in terms of the
timeliness of it and the feedback
following
following my report so i i don't think
councillor carter should feel that he's
the only one engaging with these rough
sleepers and lots of other people lots
of other people do and do report it and
action is taking us as much as is
required um
so that's
so that's on that point i just come back
to council dawson's comment regarding
the aims um in that are listed in in
section five
of the of the document and i think
she has a
um a point really because actually when
you read these aims they are act they
read more like statements rather than
aims and i think it's all to do with the
way that they're being phrased and i
think that certainly could be could be
looked at um
because there is a sort of sense that
into the way that they've written that
that are done deal with clearly is not
the case
and then finally i think coming back to
the issue of homelessness i think one of
the uh points that uh
mr king made was that that we do have a
record i think household one alluded to
this too of of a register of people
looking for homes what is not clear to
me uh possibly other councillors is
actually how many people are
at any one point are effectively
homeless and looking for homes and and
how's that trajectory moving and how we
coping with it i think is kind of where
council dawson was trying to get to with
with that particular aspect of her
question and i think that's an important
thing to understand and i do appreciate
that it is a a moving feast because you
know it'll be one thing a set of data at
one point another set of data at another
point but i think it would be good to
understand the trajectory of that
thank you
thank you very much
so
um do i have
any suggestions from anyone as to the
recommendations obviously we will accept
the report we'll thank thank the
officers for um
um presenting the report and the
information and the certainly the
answers to the questions council scarf
uh thank you chair um yeah i mean i'm
quite happy with the uh two first
recommendations but i think
uh we need uh
some further recommendations and one of
these uh in particular
refers to just the mid-socket members of
the committee
and i would move a motion which i've
given notice to robert so he's already
got it typed already hopefully
in relation to action point 3.13
this committee recommends that urgent
action is taken to build improved joined
up working with citizens advice and
recognizes that this is a top
priority furthermore the consideration
is given to creating a jointly funded
post by cabinet in order to move this
priority
and critical area forward
and my thinking there is
citizens advice in other areas have
actually
adopted this model
with some varying degrees of success but
i think if
a jointly funded post and it is down to
uh negotiations between citizens advice
and
this authority if we agree uh this as to
who is the employer and etc i think it
could be enormously useful
in my earlier comments i said i was
aware of issues
particularly with mid-suffolk ca and i
think this could be a way of actually
resolving that issue moving forward
it is so crucial i think that we have a
very good working relationship with
simpson's advice because we can divert
inquiries uh through citizens advice
they inevitably get them uh that we come
to the housing team and indeed vice
versa and
i also have some experience of it
through my work as a trustee on the
stone market relief trust and the
feedback that we get
as a relief trust in in terms of helping
people
who are quite often
absolutely desperate and have nothing
when they move into a house
and the way that we react
to them from the housing solutions team
and the way that the trust supports them
in their efforts to get established so
i'm
quite happy to move that motions so
that's a that's a proposal
we have a second or i think councillor
carter
that would that would be considered by
the mid suffolk members
um unless mid-supper members only unless
it's something that
um
no i'm getting
heads head shaken
in terms of
um baby
yes please do um i'm sorry i'm i can't
see the point in in employing one person
to actually liaise between the housing
department and um citizens advice i
don't think that's
so it's not something that you that i
would my favorite members would consider
but it is well i wouldn't i can't speak
for my colleagues but i would not
well unless i get unless i get a
proposal
from somebody from the baby side
again exactly what he said
was slightly confused here i mean
basically it's um
a recommendation that in order to
have closer working relationships
between housing officers and citizens
advice in stone market that there is a
jointly funded post or a better a closer
way of working which may well be a a
jointly funded post
um
so that there could be there could be a
a person either in stone market or
indeed
in the housing office here who
who would make sure that a person who's
got these these needs
doesn't fall through the cracks of not
if they've got a housing need if they're
demonstrating a housing need but they've
got other needs or if they're
demonstrating other needs and they've
got housing need that this person is
dealt with
um as an individual all of their needs
are looked at rather than
one group of people looking after
part of it and the housing people
looking after the housing side
so that that i understand is what we
have a proposal and a secretary for on
the mid-suffolk side
um and we will obviously have to vote
for that separately from the mid-suffolk
side could i just ask then could um
perhaps counselor
osborne advise us in baby how we do this
at the moment is it addressed
or not
sorry jim i did have my hand up i was
going to say i wouldn't recommend a
dedicated officer to deal with this
particular issue um it would need to
come within the resources of existing
officers to deal with and in fact
actually baby actually does i'm not sure
how it sits with mid suffolk but i
wouldn't recommend the recommendation as
a dedicated officer we need to put
officers in much more priority areas
although i agree that is a particular
priority but not as a dedicated officer
situation
thank you that's helpful
thank you
councilman
thank you chair yes i must admit i i
don't think i do actually agree with jan
osborne really from from the mid-soccer
point of view there was liaison between
citizen advice and our housing team
which i think is adequate but i couldn't
support like a part you know time
officer and that type of thing
so
no that's how i feel about it chairman
thank you very much
counselloreckping i think you had your
hand up a little while ago was that in
connection with this
not in connection with this uh mr
chairman
i i want to propose another
recommendation please do
so i i would like to i mean in the light
of the comments i made earlier during
the meeting i'd like to a recommendation
to be that we have a
an overhaul of the the presentation of
this report um particularly
trying to eliminate the number of
actions that are ongoing
um and making sure that um
other other actions have uh proper times
timestamps and the the commentary
related to the to them are are
appropriate
um
i think there's a little bit of a
confusion here between reviewing the
strategy which we want to do on an
annual basis which seems more than
reasonable and actually scrutinizing the
specific actions that have been set
forward to take place
and i think that clarity needs to be
brought forward in the next report
thank you
do other members generally agree with
what counteract people have said
casamulla happy to support that thank
you right
okay
is there anything else anyone would like
to add
to the recommendations
um i'll take councillor mavery first and
then councillor morley
um thank you um i thought that we were
going to make some recommendations to um
to planning regarding um
the
pre-application which i do have issues
with um from casework
um and also the the issue about
the affordable housing
and
no we'll rewind sorry um it was the
space the space um that process
there's the outside space provision yeah
their own private amenity space i.e
within the boundary of their property
thank you
thank you chair i'd just like to remind
mid suffolk councillors that mid-suffolk
already funds uh several many thousands
of pounds towards the mid-suffolk cab
for the express purpose of supporting
this area
and i
it's a bit like
find a dog and barking yourself you're
paying somebody else to do do that
function and i i don't personally see
any need for um
jointly funded
be asking citizens rights to give us
some money back to to do what we've
already asked them to do
thank you thank you
morley
sorry
i couldn't quite hear what she was
saying think i think what councilman was
saying was that
the soviet district council as do baber
um provide some funding towards citizens
advice yeah and
councillor moore he was questioning
whether it was
reasonable for the citizen advice then
to use some of that funding for a
jointly funded post
right we've got several ideas for
recommendations we haven't got anything
written out um
unless you have um
rob
would it be helpful to hear from rob and
then as if we take them one at a time if
people want to clarify or seek
clarification on any one of these then
we'll do them one at a time
thank you
all right thank you chair i apologize
for it later
so
just to confirm with the point the
proposal that was put forward by
councillor scarf um is that a
mid-suffolk only yes
yeah so we'll take that the very end
that's yeah we'll take that i'm afraid
i've put it in first because it came up
first well we can start it first
okay
um and the other one that i have so far
is that the report is reviewed with
regards to the presentation of actions
and the inclusion of day-to-day work in
the action plan
um
i've got point the point from council
and maybe i'm
not quite sure how to word that if
chair with regards to pre-application
can we just express can express concern
about the um
the
availability of private immunity space
within developments and express
and we're going to have to vote for the
for these
each of them separately
and the other was to express concern
about the adequacy of the
pre-application
service yeah pre-application service
right i will add those in their chair
do you wish to take these all separately
we will have to take them all separately
i think yes
sorry
i'll come to you in a minute councillor
mccror um i'm just trying to get
us to establish what our recommendations
might be
all right have you got
nearly that
thank you
uh
well i don't think we're very far away
from a vote and then we will then we
will have a break
you'll be able to get some fresh air
there
just trying to just sort out the precise
wording of
that there could be four or five well
probably at least five recommendations
emily
chair i just wondered actually whether
it would be opportune to take a quick uh
adjournment so that um we could take the
opportunity to craft some
recommendations
that's a brilliant idea
yes now i think council macro wanted to
say something did you want to say that
and then we'll take a break
uh all i was going to say was that this
is a review i think of the housing
strategy and it seems to me that some of
the recommendations speak
to matters of planning policy
and the planning team that may be out
with the control of the housing
department and i wondered if that would
be a consideration
you're absolutely right and i think
that's why we will make some
recommendations to planning offices and
i mean the point is
um that several members have made
they're all in the action plan and so if
we're reviewing the action plan and
they're in the strategy
so when we're reviewing the strategy so
if the strategy says we're aiming for
homes homes are of high quality
sustainable environments served by jobs
community facilities appropriate green
space effective transport links and
other necessary
infrastructure i think we have to
if we've got comments to make we need to
make those comments but we as you say we
need them to make them in the right
direction not expect that housing
officers are going to wave the magic
wand over all of these aspects
right so we'll have
shall we have ten
a ten minute break do you think 10
minutes is enough or do you rather 15
if we can have a 10 minute break we'll
all be back here at
11
52.
that'll be great
right thank you welcome back we're now
going to
hear from the governance officer the
recommendations
that we are about to vote on
thank you thank you very much chair
and so i would just read out um the ones
that we have so that everyone is clear
ahead of the vote so with relation to
councillor scarf's motion that is
unchanged except that the parenthesis
has been added in terms of making it
this committee msdc so that's
specifically related to that point um so
other than that there's no change to the
wording and the other ones are that the
content of the action plan was noted and
the committee asked for further
information on the day-to-day activities
of the action plan and this will allow
for changes to be made and reviewed
by by the officer in line with the
assistant director of housing as well so
we can take back the comments from this
meeting with regards to that as well
the next one is that the homes and
housing strategy and homelessness and
reduction sleeping strategy be reviewed
twice yearly which was the point that
was put forward by councillor dawson
so that's
that one with regards to the other
points on that were planning related
i've taken advice from the monitoring
office on that point they will be
recorded in the minutes and passed on to
their own offices but they work with
it's advised that it shouldn't be as
recommendations within this report
if that's clear
that's clear to me uh council about uh
councillor dawson sorry
i thought we'd agreed that we weren't on
the recommendations of council osborne
and
we weren't really
interested in putting in inserting here
the jointly funded post by the cabinet
well councillor cancer osborne spoke on
behalf of baber district council
and
it will be up to the mid-south district
council members whether or not
they vote for or against that as a
recommendation
it is only but it is only two
um
mid-southern district council it's not
to baby can i just come back on this
because this was what happened with the
transport at the last meeting to
remember all the mid suffolk voted for
it and baby didn't want it we don't want
to find ourselves in a situation today
where we vote against this we're
overruled by then and then this goes
forward to our cabinet now you're not
being asked to vote on this this is this
is a vote for mid-suffolk members only
and will only affect mid-suffolk
district council it won't affect baber
at all okay
thank you for the clarification
so
are we are we ready now to hear that are
we going to hear the recommendations one
at a time or are they all on the screen
now they'll be
they'll all be on the screen share but
um as i am aware that some members
aren't able to i will read it out again
when i go to the vote so that those
answering verbally can
get those points so i will start
the vote of that the content of the
action plan was noted
and the committee asked for further
information on the day-to-day activities
of the action plan
so that vote is now in progress members
and could i please ask councillor carter
for your vote verbally please
oh you've got fantastic thank you
councillor and councilman
yes of course
that the content of the action plan was
noted and the committee asked for
further information on the day-to-day
activities of the action plan
thank you
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and that is nine votes for and
so
unanimous
will now move to the next vote which is
for both sets of members
which is that the homes and housing
strategy and homelessness and rough
sleeping strategy be reviewed twice
yearly
so if you vote for that will be for
going to reviewing it twice yearly and
if you vote against that will be for
keeping as the annual review
as we have done today
so i will now start the vote on that
which will now show in progress council
margaret mabry can i take your vote
please
thank you chair that is
seven votes four and two again so that
is carried
and then finally the last
one will be for mid suffolk members only
and that is all in front of you so that
is now in progress
so in relation to action point 3.13 this
committee msdc recommends that urgent
action is taken to build improve joined
up working with citizens advice and
recommends that this is a top priority
furthermore that consideration is given
to creating a jointly funded post by
cabinet in order to move this priority
and critical area forward
thank you all votes have now been
received by the mid suffolk members
and that is three votes four and two
against so that is carried
thank you very much
that was a bit of a marathon wasn't it
but thank you very much um
thank you um
thank you to the officer for sticking
with it all for two hours um
yeah we're very grateful to to you and
please uh take our our thanks back to
the
to your colleagues for the work that
they've done in presenting them
preparing the report all the statistics
and so on thank you very much indeed
so
we are now moving on
to item eight a
i think that's right
um
eight a is the
information bulletin on customer service
the customer service
update
this is for noting but there will be an
opportunity to ask questions of clarity
so i'll ask samantha lake and sarah
wilcock to introduce the paper and then
we'll go into questions thank you very
much
thank you chair and good afternoon
councillors um so just by way of a short
introduction to the information bulletin
and and um it was requested by overview
and scrutiny that there was some
headline information provided for
face-to-face customer services and for
the time period the first of april 21
until the 31st of july 21.
and as you can see in the information
bulletin in stone market we have seen
108 customers during that period and in
sudbury 314.
the information bulletin shows the
number of customers accessing our
services and during this period and the
majority have been so um to see us for
online form support and also to provide
information for evidence
for benefits and housing information
i have noted in the report there is a
difference between stone market and
sudbury in terms of the volumes of
customers and in the main we have seen
that a number of customers have wished
to take us up on telephone appointments
rather than coming in to see us face to
face
i would like to note at this stage that
since writing this report and the
delivery of our pop-up services at
shortly and hadley will be commencing um
however it won't be at the end of
september and but from the fourth of
october and this was requested um by the
libraries themselves just due to some
changes in locations um in relation to
where we're actually sat within the
library
um i'd just like to say that as this is
an information bulletin there is no
recommendations proposed as a result of
this report and i'll hand over to the
chair for any questions for clarity
thank you thank you very much do we have
any questions
counselors
yes thank you for all the work you have
but i do have some questions only
because as you know i'm so heavily
involved
thank you for the um
the work behind the access point because
it looks far more cheerful now sadly we
still haven't managed to move
the screen because it's reflecting on
the lights so the starters is terribly
difficult to use
so that needs to be moved
um and the other thing is and proof of
life
um we still have a lot of people coming
into the town hall and the town will
have kept a tally of how many people
still thinking i know we've advertised
that we've talked about it because
people still don't appreciate that they
need to go to the library
so i don't know how many more times we
need to put that out still trying um
however um is average of about
10 a day and on market days about 19
people
still come into
the which is now the um tourist
information
and so we just need to
um i don't know how we're going to
publicize it more um but you know that
is there so
that's um just and and this proof of
life
we do have quite a few people want proof
of life if you'd like to explain to
people may not understand what that's
for
yes so um proof of life is a service
that we do provide at webre
mid-southwark district council it's very
popular actually in
mid-suffolk as
as you've mentioned as well it seems to
be in weber and it's usually for um
foreign pensions and it's provide to
provide and proof of um kind of identity
and it's a stamp that needs to be done
by an official the reason quite a lot of
people like um a council to undertake
that activity is because it's quite
often charged for in other services so
for example a legal representative may
charge for that service and it's
something that we don't charge for at
the council and in terms of your
questions councillors if i can
just
just respond to a couple of them and
thank you so much for your
your comments in terms of proof of life
i'm very happy to advertise that and
make sure that we can maybe specifically
talk about that when we're talking about
the customer access point service and in
terms of the the numbers coming into the
um town hall i appreciate there does
seem to be a lot of customers also
coming to see us to talk about tourist
information wherever possible
we're trying to sign post everybody in
the right direction so um appreciate
that and i'll do my very best to to
advertise something specifically looking
at proof of life
but also very comfortable that we are
there
on on um on those two days a week and
please feel free to let people know to
to pop in and see us and we're more than
comfortable to do a proof of life on you
but i will say the staff that you've had
in there because i i go and there's only
around the corner so it's a pain that
i'm so close but i do thank them and
they do
um and they're very good but the other
thing is some of them have indicated and
i found a tutor that could do it would
like to learn british sign language
because that is something that quite
often is needed so if we can have that
as a recommendation
um so i know that we've spoken about
british sign language before so thank
you for um for um saying that again
council raisin and i think you were
going to send me some information of a
local course that you you thought might
be most useful for my team so i'm more
than happy to to explore that once i've
received the details thank you council
oh i didn't think there'd be many
questions i had counsellor barrett first
then counselor maybe then counteracting
me first please sorry
um thank you um morning um
afternoon um
it's interesting looking at your figures
um
we've got
an and
am i right i'm thinking that you've only
been open two days a week in stone
market during this period normally it'd
be five yes
so those figures are based on only two
days a week
and yet you've got more people coming to
sudbury
than than you're seeing at stone market
well
three times as many
do can you account for that or
so i think historically we have seen
higher volumes of people requiring
face-to-face services in um
in baby versus mid-south
um
in terms of the stone market numbers as
i mentioned we have also seen a lot of
customers requiring or being quite
comfortable with a telephone appointment
rather than actually wanting to come in
and see us face to face if they would
prefer a telephone appointment what we
will do is we will call them back at
convenient time and so that they're not
worried about the the phone bill if you
will um because it could take up to 45
minutes to an hour depending on what
that inquiry is related to so we have
seen a greater uptake of people wanting
to use that service
in in stone market
yeah well i guess because sudbury is a
market town they're coming to sudbury
anyway
to do their various bits of business and
their and that's why they're face to
face
um
well it seems obvious that you need to
put more resources into sudbury and less
into stone market in the future
because you've got the demand there
you've got evidence that there is
greater demand in sudbury and yet you
presume you're going to go back to five
days a week in in stone market when
there is less demand
it doesn't doesn't seem to make sense
so i feel our face-to-face services are
always under review and we've always
said that we'll look at the demand
across both locations
and of course we'll start to deliver our
pop-up services again and across the
other two sites in in baber which will
um also support with seeing those
additional volumes of customers um in
terms of the sudbury location we do have
two offices there on those two days a
week and so although we are seeing on
average about 10 customers and
per officer that's that's quite um
doable if you will within that time
period at this point in time but of
course we will measure the demand over
time and review it as we've committed to
well it's about
probably about 24 a week for
if you count over 13 weeks
so i was assuming you weren't counting
the whole of july
april may june 13 weeks so that seems to
be about 24 people a week over two days
so should it be two offices still
because the day i popped in there was
only one officer
there is always two officers there
someone might have been on lunch for a
period of time but there is always two
officers there for the day okay um
and um the your report talks about
mediation
is that in your report
about um
on page 86.
is that part of your report
i think you've gone into the next report
okay i'll save that for
next item thank you thank you councilman
avery
yes um thank you this also
relates to sudbury um i attended with a
resident who was very very unsure of
approaching anyone else
and sadly
all the computer equipment was not
working
and we had a high on time for about an
hour but it then came back on on
stream
which was
very useful um
both of the officers who were there were
very helpful i do not deny that but it
was very very frustrating to
for the resident who
had particularly asked for me to attend
we'd
made arrangements
we had all the paperwork with us
and then the equipment wasn't working
was that a question
the question is how do we make sure that
the equipment works
well we'll take that away
i mean it relies on not just the
officers who are there but it relies on
a lot of other things besides thank you
cancer epi young
thank you mr chairman um
actually the officer in response to
councillor barrett um
has highlighted what i suspected was an
issue with the statistics being
presented on the first page of their
report
in regards to the number of customers
being seen at stone market versus
sudbury
um
[Music]
and i think this kind of led the council
bury down a particular path in terms of
resourcing and i think actually
it would be good to actually count in
the number of customers that were dealt
with by telephone as well because they
are never still customers whether we
deal with them face to face or by the
telephone uh and i think that would
perhaps show a slightly different
balance
um
so
that's the point i want to make there um
because cattle barrel already asked the
question i need i wanted to ask um on on
the next page um we talk about uh
customers not being able to
or not understanding that they can
upload information
through the online forms themselves and
i just wondered what we're doing
uh on that website to to make it more
clear to potential customers that that's
what they can do and how they can do it
because clearly if they they're clear
about that they wouldn't be needing to
to come for a face-to-face or to
approach you by phone
um
and and i think this is a sort of an
endemic thing about uh council websites
i don't think they are as clear as they
could possibly be
when uh to people using them as how best
to use them
and then finally um
[Music]
you talk about launching a
digital skills support on access and has
that actually happened and and what were
the initial feedback from that
okay thank you councillor so um i'll
take those questions in turn so in terms
of the telephone appointments apologies
um because it was focused on
face-to-face i didn't want anyone to
think that the numbers were not
reflective of people had specifically
requested face-to-face but i'm very
comfortable to make sure that um future
reports demonstrate the telephone
appointments because they are much
longer appointments as well so very
happy to do so
and in terms of making sure that our
website's clear we do um look at our
website and review it regularly to try
and make sure that
any feedback from customers and we're
trying to respond to in terms of making
the website information clearer i think
um for those particular customers quite
often they had been quite used to coming
in and providing that information and so
it just become maybe a habit rather than
it necessarily being something that
wasn't made really clear on the website
they hadn't really looked for the
information before so it's something
that um that we were able to support
them whilst they were in the um in the
library with us for example to actually
show them how to do that and so that it
did make it much easier for them moving
forwards
and in terms of the digital skill
support we are shortly launching that in
terms of it will consist of online
training which can be self-supported by
officers but also there will be a
face-to-face offer as well and we have
um also
sent out a survey to our tenants to
understand their digital skills needs as
well so
we'll be looking at our tenants
specifically as well as part of that
that particular offer which we'll be
looking to explain more to cancer
shortly
thank you very much
i'm councillor mccraw and then
councillor scarf
thank you chad sorry the microphone
wasn't quite responding um i think this
helps might help answer the questions
raised by councillor barrett regarding
the level of service provision and the
relative levels of service provision
between sudbury and stone market
after these figures were prepared for
this meeting i asked if we could get
some figures for uh sudbury earth for
august so i've got some updated figures
for august and they show pretty much the
same pattern of use
but one thing that did emerge
from that was the average
time spent with each customer and that's
approximately 13 minutes
now if we multiply the maximum number of
face-to-face contacts at sudbury which
was 107 in july multiply that by the 13
minutes
we have uh something under just over 23
hours say 24 hours of face-to-face
provision
now that's across the course of a month
and of course in the course of that
month we would be open for at least
eight days
eight and a fraction uh with two
officers so we're providing if you like
um
let me think 24 8 we're providing
potentially four times as much
uh
officer time as the face-to-face time
allowed will allowing for the fact they
have other things to do
i think that speaks to probably about
the right level of service provision
allowing gaps in between and so on
the other thing i was going to say was
that it's clear that this pattern used
in stone market considering the length
of a contact there might be 45 minutes
to an hour
so say about three times as long the
fact that it's a third of the
number of calls actually balances out in
terms of minutes used so i would suggest
and i think that's what the evidence
shows that having
any more days at sudbury would be
ineffective it wouldn't improve the
service
but reducing the days to one would also
be ineffective i think the level at two
days per week seems to be set about
right and the and the evidence supports
that thank you thank you very much
that's that's really helpful thank you
um
councillor barrett
thank you
thank you very much i'm really struck by
some of the figures that we're being
told about here um we've heard that the
telephone calls can la can take 40
minutes
but the face-to-face appointments last
about 13 minutes
why
i mean it sounds as if it's more
efficient to run a face-to-face
operation doesn't it
well i guess it's down to the type of
question if
i'm asking the question um
are in fact um
dealt with on first contact and
particularly at sudbury it's a
face-to-face operation
i'm going to be going and visiting
sudbury this week and also the stone
market call center uh hasn't been
possible up until now due to covert
restrictions but now it seems to be
sensible
so i'll get some direct contact and if i
can feed it back to the committee at any
future point i'll be happy to do so
thank you chair yeah um
one of the points i want to highlight
about stomach and i'm sure this is not
unique because i'm sure it happens at
subway as well
the the town council officers also get
inquiries about services uh
by mid-south uh i can see sudbury gets
a reasonable number of inquiries about
waste services um
i certainly know that we get inquiries
about waste services and complaints
about waste services and we refer them
onwards so
in terms of customer contact
the town council also gets a
considerable number of inquiries which
we deal with directly or assign post
them to one of the councillors within
the town uh or to the county council or
to mid suffolk so
it's a snapshot of where we're at but
there are other service providers and
i'm sure ca in in in stanford also gets
inquiries about it because there's a
general level of misunderstanding about
what each council's role and
responsibilities is
everyone says the council
and stone market obviously having
offices in the town
get a fair proportion of other councils
inquiries as well
thank you
yeah councillor laboury
about um about sudbury um i just take
this is it a question sorry it is right
you said a comment i was
just concerned mr chairman um
perhaps i'll just pass thank you now if
you've got a question please ask it no
thank you
councillor carter
regards the stone market um we have this
issue that's been reported again with
disability form how difficult it is to
get into that access point
from a
scooter perspective it's quite a
horrendous door to go through
and it offers very little way of
actually any privacy to actually ask any
questions
with viewers there
um
i did wonder with the increase
the preference is for phone calls
yet with some of our members it is they
are with learning security
especially
with a phone call you can't get the same
degree as you would face to base but
they can't get into the building
is it possible to look at doing things
like teams where it's
a camera so it's visual
cues for members for people to actually
get the face-to-face experience but not
necessarily have to do it
also if you're doing that is it not
possible to
have
rather than people in the station but
actually have
monitors so you could have of the
offices
a central location and then do radiate
out to do meetings
infer things like have an access point
in the library so somebody especially
could go press a button and want to
speak to somebody from customer service
would that would not be a more
accessible way of doing it rather than
having the single access point
um building if if if you get what i mean
with that
granted it would have the issue of the
computer gremlins from time to time but
would that not be easier for to be able
to reach more customers without having
to send people out to
separate access points
um
and there was something else but for
life for me it's completely gone so i'll
i'm might have to ask another question
later
um i shall try and respond to those so
um in terms of the access and
specifically at stone market i know we
have had um the disability forum come
and view our premises and try and make
some recommendations which we have put
into place to try and improve
that access point to make sure that
everybody does feel so that they can
enter comfortably
since the pandemic we have also limited
the numbers of people that come in so it
is a one to one in that main office area
to allow greater space for that person
to have a conversation and with the
officer
in terms of the team's appointments and
that ability to be able to deliver
virtual kind of appointments it is
something that we are exploring um and
we are working with mid suffolk citizens
advice on that also because i know that
that's something that they're currently
offering um in a few locations so we are
working with them actively on that
thank you thank you
um
councillor dawson
very quickly
a counselor um sorry uh not counsellor
our chief executive mr chavez very
kindly always said we would have um
the uh some sort of uh communication
with residents in hadley library that's
been pulled
and sudbury's is obviously also
diminished
uh you know we've got ten thousand
pounds ten thousand people in hadley and
it serves a larger wider community
so you know is
is something going to be done or coming
back there or was that now just being
shelved contrary to what was originally
agreed
are we sorry are we talking about hadley
library yes yes that's coming back from
week commencing the 4th of october and
will that be a person sitting there was
it another sort of um just a laptop
sitting at a desk it's two people
sitting there lovely thank you very much
thank you
are they
i don't see any other hands i don't see
any other ques um
i'd really like to um
we've focused a bit on on coverage and
so on i'd like to just ask about the the
sort of level of uh officer um their
training and their background
what grade officer are they who are
attending are they both the same or
for both locations
in terms of our offices who are
attending the customer access points
they are the same grade so it's grade
three
three right so that's admin
level
do you have grade four officers
available we do and they're usually
based in a customer access point
alongside the grade three officers so
they're the team leaders um and they're
usually in a customer access point so
it's two offices one is usually grade
three one is a grade four
so one is a grade three but only the
grade three's visit do you mean
so there's two offices in each customer
access point so when we go to say
um
you know when we start again at hadley
it will be two offices one is a grade
three one is a grade four officer and
that's the same that sudbury is it yes
the majority of the time wherever that's
available yes thank you thank you very
much
thank you everybody this item this
information bulletin is for noting thank
you very much for presenting the
the paper thank you very much indeed
so
now
we yeah we've got we've got some people
coming to present
the information bulletin on anti-social
behaviour
but we need to do a bit of swapping
around people in order to accommodate
them
yeah certainly yeah
thank you very much
you
so we now have
peter watson and ian rafferty
to introduce their paper
the information bulletin on antisocial
behavior
this is for noting only but you may ask
questions
for points of clarification when they
have finished their presentation
thank you very much
we are ready when when you are
well good afternoon councillors i'm
peter watts i'm the community safety
project manager favorite suffolk mission
this is our first baptism if you like
into the ovum scrutiny committee so i
take everyone has seen the paper that
has been drawn up
okay
would you like to just walk through that
would you like to
if everybody has are there any one or
two points that you particularly want to
bring to our attention i think what i'd
like to do is that i i started work at
last december just give you a very brief
overview of the travel since then so
you're probably aware there was the
anthony douglas report commissioned last
year from that that was the platform for
us to take a review of all the policies
and procedures within the asb world
to do with training about communications
both internally externally the platforms
regarding networking so the paper i've
done is just an overview of
what has been happening during the last
nine months i've broken down to certain
particular areas
within our area of community safety what
we have actually done is
increased capacity and capability
last year was just one professional
league thanks dean jones we've now
migrated away from that we'll look at a
new restructure from next month where
potentially appoint another asb officer
the work that we we do covers obviously
both weber and miss suffolk
what i can say is that from the review
process we've we've done we are in a
much better healthier place what i mean
by that is we've put everything under
the microscope regarding our policies
and procedures we've done i've done a
complete review of the community trigger
process there's 23 recommendations from
that i've looked at and reviewed the
panel meetings which were chaired they
were usually chaired by monthly i've now
increased that to a monthly
a monthly process
what was
needed was a software package
to hold our cases and communicate
externally and internally so it's a
better case management that's called
esims
which has been rolled out we've been
doing training on on that side also many
months ago done some training for
councillors to give a much broader
picture of the complexity of asb i think
asdn itself creates perhaps just a very
narrow tunnel vision of what we actually
do get involved with respect it is a
very wide subject both from civil and
criminal talks
so you can cover hate crime you have
domestic homicide reviews
uh
county lines criminal exploitation
radicalization there's a whole broad
depth of
different subjects which requires
different skill sets so that's why i'm
in our eni here so a little bit about
perhaps the background would be relevant
i was five years management in asb at
which borough council prior to that i
spent 25 years of fraud investigations
in the public private sector
ian's background
i come from a policing background
service of the police for 30 years
so you can see between us we have
extensive experience in different fields
and what we've been looking at is not
just about what needs to be changed and
addressed from perhaps last year but
providing a platform so both our staff
are trained which they have been
on the new legislation but also looking
to the future about where we sit and
what we can do proactively because i
don't like to have a reactive start i
think we need to be on the front foot so
we've been gathering momentum from that
side and the report here is a flavor of
where we've been and what we're doing
regarding little snippets regarding cctv
perhaps the mediation side which i know
you want perhaps to lead to
and also the community trigger process
and on that point uh the community
process from april 2016 to january of
this year there hadn't been one single
case review conducted since i've been
here we've had five applications and not
one of those has gone to the appeal
stage so it's effective it's working
this came about from the asp awareness
week in
may june every month it was we've
engaged with the public we've engaged
with the police we've got our networking
going on this afternoon ian just tell
about the the point we've got this
afternoon this it's important yeah it is
it's um it's part of an ongoing process
where we're liaising with our partners
this afternoon i'll be talking to the
police the as an officer for schools
effectively what we're trying to do is
to get our message out to young people
not just for our schools but via
other clubs and other youth
organizations
so one of the strands we're working on
is to
raise awareness of asb
with the target age group in schools
part of that is um re-engaging with the
crucial crew then if you're aware of
crucial crew multi-agency educational
tool
talking to children about their safety
online safety as well as
in real life so lots and lots of strands
going on
it's ongoing and as peter said we're
hoping to become
proactive rather than reactive
thank you
the other part is
it's about personalising our work
our customers they're not numbers
they're real people with real issues but
what i'm looking to do is ancient near
what's called an asp champion this is
someone who's been through the process
of being a victim all the way through to
the courts
and using that person to engage with a
penitential victim it takes away the
official them i used it when i was at
richborough council to great effect so
that's that's the other revenue we're
looking at is making sure that we
communicate with our public
and they have the availability to
communicate with us so it's a very
personal matter
can you go on a bit more but that's fine
thank you
councillor mueller
thank you very much indeed
um
yes you say off your liaison with the
police on a regular basis do you
actually liaise with the engagement
officer for mid-suffolk pc henriksen
because he meets our street meets once a
month which i joined him at
as well and i wonder whether you sort of
you mentioned the school's liaison
police officers and i just wonder
whether you met with the engagement
officer as well
yeah thank you council thank you
question um yes stefan is somebody that
i've already lays with good
in fact i lays with him prior to or
during the compilation of this very
report
and what i wanted from him was his view
of
asb
in his area
where the hot spots were and what his
real concerns were
now that's only an email
back and forth with stefan
but um as i get longer further into this
role we'll certainly develop that
relationship and what we want to do
together with our partners is to get
that message out
we had a street meet and
pop-up event in sudbury in july
and in and around
asb we were there with the police
answering questions remember the public
and really trying to raise awareness
amongst them
and
part of that
is hoping to
[Music]
allow they'll give them the feeling that
they were able to speak to us
we would listen
and we would then offer solutions
thank you would that be possible for you
to do a similar arrangement with stefan
his next one i believe is on the 16th of
october
um
next month which again i will also be
attending with that we'll just give an
example we had the modern slavery
officer
with us last month or this month and
also the missing persons officers i
think that would be very useful we do
get very good engagement with members of
the public
the council i agree entirely and that is
something we'll work on thank you very
much thank you thank you could i just
answer that isn't it it's an important
question so
from the police engagement side and
monthly panel meetings chair they are
invited and they do attend but also
importantly we're part of what's called
an air tactical command group meeting
which has senior police officers dealing
with
high-risk
crime should we say and so we have a
place on that panel
and we engage with certain elements
which is the higher level of asp so we
have got that communication and we are
recognized
from there thank you very much you're
welcome
thank you
any other
questions
yes thank you i'd like the opportunity
to to sort of raise a couple of points
um
one is that in my
ward uh there are a couple couple of
villages where they have a large influx
of young people in the summer evenings
because you know there's areas where
they can um
jump in the river and and sort of party
viewers and mainland and they've the
aonb are hosting two seasonal rangers
who will be
paid for by baber i don't i wondered if
you'd had any contact or will liaise
with them at all because they'll be out
on the
on the patch looking at potential
anti-social behavior
um
i don't mind um
is that where you deal with individual
cases
here or joint video separate okay
raise it separately with you yeah i mean
i have heard of these issues before
about behaviour of young people it's
about what we do with them and
operationally about the educational side
and so i'm more than happy to engage
with you outside the meeting on there
yeah i just wondered if you'd had
already not knowledge of the seasonal
range
yeah okay and the other thing is um your
the report that we've got um
uh uh has uh information about the
mediation that you you offer so is that
between two sort of parties that are
in a sort of headlock
okay so conflict to answer your question
about mediation
the way it works is that we have a
structured tiered approach to managing
asb the mediation sits within that
structure
where we identify
a situation which we don't want to
penalize or criminalize
we feel that there is a
acceptable need for a conversation
between two parties we will use
mediation because they are trained
professionals
start from baby itself are not trained
mediators so that's why
i've
got this contract catch-22
and they will engage about the
communication side but what it does it
doesn't necessarily mean that both
parties have to agree to it ideally you
would
and
it's only a voluntary
so you could just have one person they
can engage with that where the other
person does not engage
so it allows us a more efficient use of
our time
because they are trying to do that
it allows officers well to be side
posted to
deal with the case work week become weak
to do it that way if that fails then we
go to the next tier where there could be
a sanction involved this is about
also
i think about taking officialdom away
from it because sometimes some people
have a residence to be involved on that
side so it's about using
all your knowledge and would think is
this an appropriate set of circumstances
sometimes it is and obviously sometimes
it isn't
by my experience
from
a previous authority
the success rate was around 83
whereby the engagement took place in the
success because it never went to a
different level so it for me it does
work okay so the 80 is where you've
you don't see a recurrence of the
problems coming back a few months later
i think the problem i think part of it
is people don't know how to communicate
with between victim and perpetrator they
don't know how to
have that conversation
you know if you've got an issue with
your neighbour
it's not a comfortable conversation is
it and some people are don't want to do
that or if they do it they don't do it
in the right way constructively but this
is my problem what solutions are there
to it
there's a gift to that that conversation
and not really not everyone has it so
that's why the mediation contract has
been signed out okay thank you very much
i had
uh
what did i have next
okay was it have you spoken about i
think you were yeah i think you were
next counselor
and then councillor mayberry
and then i think councillor dawson
thank you mr chairman um
thank you gentlemen you've provided a
lot of uh different statistics in your
report
and
[Music]
and you picked out the um the number of
incidents in particular
on pages 77 and 78 across the counties
of east anglia
and
as those tables stood they didn't really
do a lot for me but i decided to recast
the tables in a slightly different way
and what's very interesting is and i
have before i say that i have one
question i'm assuming that the the
numbers per population takes account of
the population growth
uh during the periods
that's correct yes yeah and i'm assuming
that does take account of the shifting
population over the time period i i
imagine it does but i don't know how
often that shift is measured okay i
can't answer that accurately for you
right here i don't think it makes a huge
amount of difference to my question
because when you then look at over that
three-year period across
all of the
six counties
what i have noticed um either in
absolute numbers or in in numbers per
thousand population is the fact that
a cambridgeshire hertfordshire and
norfolk have hardly seen a shift really
in the number of incidents whereas the
other three counters include including
suffolk uh in particular have seen quite
a significant shift and i just wondered
if you had any
explanation for why we would
cease as
a bigger shift than anywhere else
so i i mean the only the the outlier of
course is bedfordshire
i think my answer to that
good searching question is that the data
i represent what
is reported
therefore if there's better reporting
in one county to another you're going to
get to configure there will be a
contrast
that's not a scientific article question
because in truth it's difficult to
answer it because i don't have that
material with me today
i don't mind taking it away to try and
find out a better answer to the question
if you're happy with that i would be
happy if you did that because i think it
may reveal some insights that might be
useful in in the work that you're doing
and
what maybe
us as counselors can do to support you
thank you council one of the ideas
really was to provide you with a
national picture
for a comparative study
that was the reason for the inclusion of
those figures okay um second question um
the the um
the asb cpa 2014
we understand wants to look at
a victim-first approach
which is i think a good move a very good
move
so i'm a bit curious as to the statement
that's made at the bottom of page 78
um
in relation to the mental health trust
i'm just supposing that something's gone
wrong in the transcribing because
um
under challenges
yes challenges so
fifth paragraph down on the challenges
the uh
the last sentence that to me doesn't
make sense because it it does say that
it's it in some cases causing the asb to
be managed on a more victim-focused
basis i thought that was what we were
doing anyway
so
has something been missed there okay so
what what i'm trying to say here the
antisociable policing act was introduced
in 2014. the emphasis the golden thread
behind that was victim first
that came about from the pilgrimage case
and so what they did is there's a safety
net called occasionally on a community
trigger so my focus is for us to offer
that service
victim first we have to get our own
counseling order the policies the
procedures and the certain things
influencers we can
deal with regarding the mental health
that's always been
a challenging area
and what i mean by that
is that
with mental health there's different
stages to that and it deals with their
capacity as well
under the care act because you can have
capacity but it can be fluctuating
i can have it right in this minute ten
minutes later i might not have
that's a very small example of what i'm
dealing with regarding mental health
from my side the working side what i
wanted to do is promote the council that
we identify those people those voices
which go unheard
the plan is to use our location officers
planners that we go out there we've been
out there to onto the streets we've been
absolutely to some of the uh areas where
there's hot spots to find out and listen
what's been going on so the golden
thread is that we represent ourselves
out in the community and that they
actually know what we can do i think
part of the problem is that our
customers
aren't aware of our services
ourselves with asb
so that's that's the sort of
2022 pro
is to promote ourselves
mr just one more question um
with regard to your asb charts so the
bar graphs for baber and mid suffolk
would it be safe to assume that the
figures for august were not for a whole
month
you're correct yes that really should
have
excluded those figures because they're
misleading
thank you
uh counselor mayberry
thank you thank you very much and i'm
good to meet both of you and thank you
for coming today um
my question is about noise
and believe it or not i've picked up on
here there um
there is there is a report that noise
complaints in baylor and mid-suffolk
were 641 in 20 19 20 and 815 in 2021
so an increase of 27.1 percent
um
my question to you is
how do you deal with the motorbikes
that use
what shall i say
um
abandoned land because i'm talking about
an airfield just outside of sudbury
and they go round and round and random
random rounds and do all this illegal
trail use
um and i can tell you i lay in bed at
night at quarter past 10 at night and i
can hear it and i thought it was only me
until i have lots of residents
complaining to me about it
the police have attended
do you deal with that as well please
okay thank you for that question
counselor so what we're talking about
here is activity on private land
it's actually owned by suffolk county
council
so let's answer the question in two
different ways then let's assume
so got an education here if it was
private land can we intervene
no but the police can do it it's causing
a nuisance if it was on our land it'd be
different we could even introduce a
public space protection order well i'm
sure i'm not sure i can find a piece
that's owned by baber up there because
it's a very large area
so if it was our land or in a public
space we'd be introduced to public space
protection order and there's a certain
restriction on that
about vehicle
nuisance so if someone was found to do
that you offer them a fixed penalty
notice if they fail to pay that and
that's becomes an offence to which we
take the court
that's the criminalization side on the
much more soft way approaching it other
than the words advice on police you can
use your community protection notices
only where it is on private land our
jurisdiction ends there
okay
okay thank you i will be able to take
that back to a parish council meeting
this week so thank you thank you very
much thank you councillor dawson um yes
i may ask um i've read this and
my question is really with regards to
the tenants management
and anti-social behavior
when you've got seven and a half
thousand tenancies and and i'm sure you
had a number of complaints
um
i know i'm not going to talk about an
individual case but my understanding of
this is
um i had
last year
um one particular very challenging case
it came to it was by a military guy who
did this file i've never seen anything
like it was about his formal complaints
was very efficient about it
went through all the hoops his neighbors
cut long story short been in prison
drugs everything but when it came to the
mediation because this woman had
children it was made really quite clear
that at no point really
when they jumped through all these hoops
we ever going to move these people
and i'm interested to know um in the
last year
of the mediation you've been involved
with
perhaps with tenants
has that position changed have we ever
you know there are going to be problem
cases and it just seems that they have
their rights
we mediate but actually there are
perhaps some difficult families
and the the problem i've ended up in now
is we have a whole area
it's pike in a way a difficult area of
hadley
where the whole estate is now upset
because this one family hasn't been
removed and at mediation
you're not able to you can set
parameters but actually you can never
really do anything is that correct
there's a number of things you said
there counseling
can we be quite careful because this is
a public meeting and that is an
individual case and well i'm trying to
be a bit not too specific yet i think
it's all
it's not far from being identifiable
the question i'm really asking is have
we ever really
evicted any social because my
understanding is we haven't and we've
had all the we have all these services
available but actually with problem
families
we we can't really when it gets down to
the crocs deal with it i've been a
magistrate for 13 years so i fully
understand the issues surrounding this
okay so there's two answers to your
question
i'll explain the makeup of where we sit
because we are not tenancy management
intensive management is dealt with by
another team and i deal with everything
else in the private sector however i can
help ask you a question
if i've got this correctly you're
talking about the eviction
process well it's the mediation you're
you're doing the mediation with these
families when they come together
and it doesn't seem to really work is
the evidence i've been presented with
on
this is the question how successful is
the mediation
uh because we don't want to look at if
there's one case where it wasn't
successful we don't want to talk about
that one case
is it normally successful okay well
after mediation has failed
what then okay well it hasn't i know i'm
pretty sure i know the case you're
referring to i don't know we have to be
very careful what we say here so in a
general
sense
the mediation gives us the platform to
look at all
other options available to us and
sometimes in a public eye
we cannot always tell them what we're
going to be doing
but we are working behind the scenes so
it may be for example i've been very
general that we're working to engineer
and move for the family as opposed to
the eviction room because as you well
know the eviction route is something
which is
we provide the evidence to the court but
it's the court actually decides whether
the order's
granted or not
not for ourselves so your mediation is
the discussions about
if your victim is the ultimate
what can we do before then to use both
victims
and support health and perpetrator as
well there's lots of different processes
there's lots of different legal
frameworks we have to consider for
example just care act the human rights
act we have to look at proportionality
in the public interest there's a whole
different world of different things out
there so your mediation
is the one vehicle used to think where
can we take this to a better place
other than eviction
does that help no not really because
that doesn't seem to happen i don't
think in baber i i don't know
of any
anywhere after mediation really where
it's got any further it's my
understanding um could i could i say
that there may be things here which
you could talk to the counselor about in
private that you can't really
talk talk about here if would it be
helpful if you were to get in touch with
each other and tools
i think i i think that that would
probably be better
i mean i've had some involvement where
there'd been problems with particular
residents
but i certainly wouldn't want to raise
anything about them here because i
well i think i think they're best dealt
with on a one-to-one if i could just add
to the records that that kind of
conversation needed to be held with
senior leadership team because
ultimately they make that kind of
decision not myself
yes okay
yeah thank you
um
councillor carter
and then i don't have anybody else
yes
so
of my fund has been uh stolen by council
at epcon because i was going to ask
whether or not you'd be happy for it
contact outside of this meeting regards
how we could help you further
um
especially bear in mind via
that time the strengths of this meeting
today
um
part but we'll be
my apologies for
blocking up oh
i was pleased to hear you talking about
the careful purpose of it just works it
solve this
victim first it does offer some concern
to me
because bearing in mind it's quite often
a perpetrator is also either a victim
themselves and acting out further
um
it could have due to either mental
health or due to sense
due to
autism and development sometimes which
we have the increase of
and also the increase of complaints of
audio from being locked in with uh
covert
our tendency has been to
to react more
and
cope with less
it it builds it
we wish so that is a it does concern me
regards it it could be a case of
who shouts loudest first
gets seen as a perp as the victim
whereas the other way around you know
it's
either for a
mediator first approach rather than a
victim-first approach
having the external person being the
focus
being able to take both sides of the
coin and be able to handle it better
rather than the person being seen as
i got i
i approached first therefore i'm going
to get the uh attention first which i've
had cases
where it's come down to whereas how it's
been perceived
especially of uh members who have had
issues um outside of what's been
tackled in the in the case
so i appreciate contacting you
regardless outside possibly going
through the
um there
uh
yeah um
and also you may have noticed in the
media there is a expected rise of
anti-social behavior
that's
it was it reported in a number of papers
yesterday but it was it statistically
were expecting it
um
i was pleased to see that we're having a
proactive approach but do we have a plan
and play place
for the expected rise
um is is there a reason to be concerned
or is it something we're going to tackle
as and when it happens
there's two parts that the first part
i'm going to refer to
and i'll deal with the second part okay
thank you
you mentioned in the first part
yeah
apologies sorry
you mentioned victim first and is it who
shouts either the loud list or who
shouts first
and i'd say definitely not
each case
if we were to judge every case on
a first account
then we might go badly wrong
part of the investigation is to dig a
little bit deeper
to find out
what is below the surface what's really
going on here before any
solutions or roots are mapped out so
certainly not
whoever shouts the loudest
we're going to investigate we're going
to look below the surface
and get as many accounts as possible
before we or so that we can see the
bigger picture
so i hope that helps you in fact we've
got a case at the moment where
initially a perpetrator
is in fact being treated as a victim
in that particular case so i hope that
puts your mind at rest in in relation to
that could we rephrase it then in
reports rather than victim first because
it does
have a common connotation that may be
taken
yeah i think the victim first comes from
the victim code of practice which were
revised in april this year
and there were ten main points to that
but uh yeah i'll take your point and we
can we can make another maybe yeah
your second point counselor was about
resources in effect you're expecting
this kind of tsunami of complaints to
arrive on our doorstep having already
pre-empted that we've looked at our
capacity and capability
there's no point having offices in place
if they don't know how to actually
manage asb so we've had internal
training
we're well experienced and knowledgeable
in the subject it's about making sure
that we have the right structure
infrastructure as well and part of that
is what i alluded to earlier is about
the software system esems
that is a good vehicle for us to use
it's about training your officers about
awareness the source about the first
point of contact for the public
so that the the website has been changed
so that the referral mechanism is a
better cycling process it's more
efficient and quicker side posts the
road area it's environmental tendency
management onto my doorstep so i'm aware
of these
suggestions that will be arise
i tend to
take it with a pinch of salt and see
what happens but we are primed and ready
as best we can
thank you very much
do we have a
follow-up system regardless what is it
just a case dealt with event
that's it or do we follow up these cases
because it is a concern that uh it may
continue to perpetuate or it may prop up
again do we just deal with it as it
happens or do we keep an eye on the
individuals involved to ensure that it
doesn't crop up again
thank you for that question in fact
only recently i've begun to review
the first cases that are
dealt with as such so although that case
is filed and i'll then review with the
with the complainant or with the victim
the current status of that complaint in
other words
was your problem solved if not
where are we in that
in that process so yes we do revisit
them after a reasonable amount of time
and i've already started that process
okay
could i just briefly add to that we do
what's called a ram risk assessment
matrix
so if we go to meet a member of the
public their their case is actually
assessed and graded and stored whether
it's high risk medium risk for low risk
and we can revisit that ramp
periodically and when we finish with a
case we
design what's called an exit strategy we
don't just close the case and have no
communication with the victim
we go along and engage
from that side to make sure they're
happy with what the process has been and
that we can close the face down
thank you
we have got to move on because we're in
danger of losing people which would mean
we would be in quarry and we'd have to
come back another day so i'm going to go
to councillor scarf and then we're going
to then we're just going to note this
this information bulletin so questions
from councillor scarf please thank you
chair well phrasing it as a question
then could i ask that
in future reports
detailing the cct
division
cct the provision within both areas or
perhaps a little bit more expansive on
the mid suffolk side
because it sort of just one line um and
just for members information
the town council has actually spent 40
000 pounds this year on upgrading the
cctv network in stone market and that is
the second major upgrade since the 2006
installation
this doesn't give perhaps as full a
picture of the work that's been done in
the area thank you very much
so
this information bulletin is for noting
so thank you very much indeed for coming
along
and answering our questions
we've just got three other very quick
items i hope the forthcoming decisions
list do any members have any comments on
the forthcoming decisions list
as there are no questions or comments
thank you the forthcoming decisions list
is for noting
they we now have two work plans the baba
and the baby work plan and the
mid-suffolk work plan they are quite
similar because most of our meetings are
going to be joint meetings
do i have any comments on either of
those two please
no thank you very much
uh those work plans are for noting that
concludes the meeting and the next
meeting will be a joint overview and
scrutiny meeting and it will be held on
the 18th of october
at 9 30. thank you very much indeed
you